bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce premier
rendez vous quai faire trois centres vhu
fixe au cours du magazine santé ainsi va
la vie magazine santé donc qui traitera
de sujets médicaux ont certes mais pas
uniquement puisque on parlera de tout ce
qui concerne votre santé c'est à dire
aussi bien des problèmes d'environnement
que les problèmes de la sécurité sociale
par exemple un premier numéro
entièrement consacré à la rentrée qui
est dans deux jours maintenant la
rentrée ce sera le 8 septembre un jeudi
matin et le matin ça commence par le
petit déjeuner un moment très important
mais bien trop souvent négligé sous nos
climats
alors pour que vos enfants attaque d'un
bon pied eh bien nous vous proposons de
voir ce cas vrai petit déjeuner doit
être émis qu'est ce que tu manges le
matin à ton petit déjeuner sur un bon tu
manges comme ça tous les matins tu
prends des petits suisses ou du jus de
fruits oui et puis tu manges tous les
matins du pain et de la confiture et
puis tu aimes bien voir un jus de fruits
ou des fruits frais avec ton petit
déjeuner thème bien prendre mon petit
déjeuner et mines a bien raison d'aimer
prendre son petit déjeuner grâce à ce
repas à la porte à son organisme les
éléments indispensables pour lui permet
de travailler à l'école de jouer aussi
d'assurer sa croissance
encore faut-il que ce repas soit bien
équilibrée pour cela deux types
d'éléments sont indispensables tout
d'abord le lait ou les produits lactés
comme les yaourts le fromage ou un autre
mais ces produits apportent de la
vitamine a de la vitamine d et surtout
du calcium indispensable à la croissance
osseuse et s'ils réalisent ensuite
contenu dans le pain les biscuits ou les
corn flakes elles aussi sont
indispensables elle apporte les sucres
lents essentiellement l'amidon véritable
carburant pour les efforts à long terme
si les sucres lents sont indispensables
les sucres rapides que l'on trouve dans
les confitures ou les jus de fruits
industriels doivent être consommés en
faible quantité
il joue certes un rôle de starter mais
en trop grande quantité ils peuvent
endommager la denture alors les petits
déjeuners bien fait et bien pris c'est
comme une sorte de bon départ dans les
grands chemins de la vie bonne rentrée
emeline
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
les petits déjeuners bien fait bien pris
et puis aussi variés et pour cela nous
vous proposons par exemple deux exemples
de petits déjeuners dans laquelle on
retrouve tout ce que nous avons proposé
de prendre
et puis si vous voulez en savoir plus
vous pouvez vous adresser au comité
français d'éducation pour la santé dont
l'adresse s'inscrit maintenant sur votre
écran ils ont pour vous une brochure
très complète et très utile dans ce
domaine qui dit petit déjeuner d'y lever
matinal bien sûr et pour se lever le
matin d'un bon pied mais il faut cette
couche est relativement tôt le soir de
plus en plus les enfants et peut être un
peu à cause de la télévision n'hésitons
pas à nous battre les flancs les enfants
donc sont de véritables zombies le matin
arrive à l'école à moitié endormi parce
qu'ils vont de plus en plus tard au lit
et pour éviter que cela se produise trop
souvent eh bien il ya des conseils
simples à respecter et dominique beaune
stein nous rappelle ces quelques vérités
bien utile les vacances sont maintenant
terminées il va falloir reprendre les
bonnes habitudes et apprendre à se
coucher tôt et je me couche très tard et
8 herman cet impératif systématiquement
tous les soirs tu te couches à la même
heure là des fois c'est quelques minutes
plus tard mais bon pour moi c'est
toujours à la même heure pourquoi ce
toit qu'ils demandent c'est est parent
qui peut non ses parents qu'il demande
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pas comme pendant
les vacances des vacances avant j'avais
beaucoup la télé ce soir
alors ils m'ont prise un peu sur sa
normale pas beaucoup qui voudrait que
chaque est leur sortie c'est libre si on
est célibataire et aimerait regarder le
film jusqu'à la fin et après aller me
coucher les enfants ont des journées
aussi longue que les nôtres l'effort qui
leur est demandé est intense un effort
intellectuel pour assimiler les
programmes chargés un effort physique
qui exige la discipline la récréation
est courte les heures de sport souvent
inexistantes en primaire c'est pourquoi
la quantité de sommeil nécessaire ne
doit pas être laissée à la seule
appréciation de l'enfant
crois que l'enfant a besoin
globalement d'une dizaine d'heures de
sommeil je crois qu'on les parents les
parents ne font pas d'une manière
générale devant les parents ne font pas
dormir les enfants assez regardé pendant
les vacances comme ils dorment
pourquoi est ce que pendant l'année et
d'engrais pas en tant qu'entité de
sommeil bien sûr mais aussi qualité car
le sommeil se prépare dans la détente
les parents doivent prendre le temps de
coucher eux mêmes leurs enfants de leur
raconter une histoire par exemple et ce
petit quart d'heure qui précède le
coucher
c'est aussi un moment privilégié pour
discuter avec l'enfant aujourd'hui le
principal ennemi c'est bien sûr la
télévision à laquelle même les parents
succombe auront beaucoup et puis le
travail des parents les parents rentrent
tard chez eux ils en ont ils embarquent
sur la tête ils n'ont pas le temps de
s'occuper du gamal et ils ont le dinh a
préparé il faut faut faire plein de
choses alors que ce soit eu jane et puis
le gosse pour pas de gosses
il est par s'en occupe pas et puis les
parents aiment bien regarder leur
émission préférée leur film tout ça
alors bombay dès 8h30 peuvent ça
commence on n'a pas le temps de coucher
le gamin alors le gamin il traîne sur le
tapis puis s'endort sur le tapis ou où
on lui dit à 9h aller vite vite il est
l'heure d'aller se coucher l'enfant qui
a commencé à regarder l'émission et ses
parents il n'a pas envie ça fait des
drames et ses proches compte c est ça
crée une tension qui n'est kenny faste
pour le sommeil sont incontestablement
se coucher tôt c'est une bonne habitude
à prendre et tout peut se passer dans la
bonne humeur
[Applaudissements]
et puis pour terminer ce premier
rendez-vous nous voudrions vous proposer
un sujet qui avaient déjà été diffusées
sur cette antenne en mars 1982 un sujet
que nous avons choisi de vous
représenter parce qu'il symbolise un peu
ce qu'est l'école c'est-à-dire une école
universel ouverte à tous ce sujet va
vous emmener dans une classe un peu
particulière une classe d'enfants
trisomiques 21 trisomiques 21 c'est le
nom correct que l'on emploie pour ne pas
dire enfants mongolien alors qu'est ce
que c'est le mongolisme est bien chez le
sujet normal les cellules qui commence à
fabriquer l'être c'est-à-dire après la
fécondation se multiplient et ensuite se
divisent pour donner des cellules
identiques et ses petits traits noirs
que l'on voit ici c'est ce que l'on
appelle des chromosomes
c'est eux qui contiennent toutes les
informations concernant notre vie la
couleur de nos cheveux les maladies que
nous n'aurons que nous aurons que nous
n'aurons pas une cellule normale
multiplie ses chromosomes qui sont au
nombre de 46 et en donnent ainsi 46 à
chacune de ces cellules filles dans le
monde gaullisme il se passe une erreur
au lieu de répartir équitablement ses
chromosomes dans les cellules et bien
une cellule ramasse trois chromosomes
d'un groupe au lieu de deux c'est ce
qu'on appelle les chromosomes du groupe
g il y en a trois ici et un seul là il
suffit de cette petite erreur d'une
petite division pour que l'enfant soit
toute sa vie un enfant mongolien il y a
à tour comme d'autres dans d'autres
villes de france maintenant une place
une classe d'enfants presque comme les
autres
intégré dans une école publique l'école
jules renard et cette classe d'enfants
va permettre à ces enfants trisomiques
21 de suivre une scolarité jusqu'à l'âge
de 14 ans au moins pour leur permettre
d'apprendre à se débrouiller dans la vie
courante
d'apprendre aussi à lire cette cour de
récréation de l'école primaire jules
renard à tour ya neuf élèves d'une
classe un peu différente des eaux
neuf enfants handicapés âgés de huit à
dix ans ce sont des trisomiques 21 ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler plus
crûment des mongoliens depuis la rentrée
scolaire de septembre à l'initiative de
parents réunis au sein d'une association
l'éducation nationale accueille sept
classes intégrées dans la direction de
l'action sanitaire et sociale assure le
fonctionnement à la fois médical et
financier
une vraie classe dans une véritable
école avec son institutrice spécialisée
qui assurera l'éducation de ses enfants
jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans
[Musique]
te donne une feuille à tout le monde tu
donnes une feuille sur la table de noël
à venir
on en a déjà fait des choses comme fin
ale michael caine 13 d'accord tu
regardes bien regarde bien qu'elle
dessins coloriés tu regardes bien si le
grand ailier attention classe aller du
fait pareil du coloris celui qui était
cool en fait c'est le gaulliste et le
crayon été coloriées est ce que le
trayon été coloriées maulin lequel
italienne façon là la première vous je
crois que tu avais pas bien regardé je
te montre à venir tu regardes bien le
regard boury le dernier du regard
l'intérêt d'intégrer de tels enfants est
d'abord d'essayer de faire connaître et
par les enfants de l'école ordinaire et
par les parents
l'intérêt au niveau de notre travail
personnel est d'abord un travail
d'équipé puisque il y a des paramédicaux
qui travaillent avec moi et qui
travaille vraiment dans le même objectif
que moi qui travaille d'un point de vue
pédagogique
alors bien sûr on a comme objectif la
lecture ou quelques acquisitions
scolaires dit aux scolaires mais surtout
une très grande autonomie
et un épanouissement maximum de ses
enfants et de l'extérieur vers eux dans
l'équipe paramédicale autour de
françoise l'écureuil isabelle
orthophoniste dominique
psychomotricienne frédéric
kinésithérapeute mais aussi jean-louis
comédiens aient des enfants s'adapter
aux exigences du quotidien sous diverses
formes aussi bien en leur faisant jouer
des situations concrètes qu en
rééduquant une musculature défaillante
depuis la naissance
on met le poussin sas et qu'est ce qu'on
fait on se met debout debout debout et
on s'assoit way vient maintenant monter
sur la table
allez on s'assure aller ouais ouais on
recommence une fois encore on descend
[Musique]
apprendre à vivre la différence est
aussi ça une des missions de l'école
tout de suite notre adresse si vous
souhaitez nous adresser du courrier nous
poser des questions auxquelles nous
essaierons de répondre
voilà elle s'inscrit devant vous il ne
me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter le bon
soir ainsi va la vie
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]